bienvenue sur tv 78 heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau rendez vous en
cette période de confinement si on
rentrait nous allons mettre de côté
l'actualité pour tenter de vous divertir
un peu et vous donner quelques idées
d'activités pardon à faire tout seul ou
en famille chez vous en tout cas dans un
instant nous allons donc eu cuisine et
cette semaine ce sera avec le restaurant
italien dolia nova pour réaliser la
recette originale des pâtes carbonara
c'est à dire sans crème à suivre
également une sélection de livres à
découvrir en partenariat avec le pavé du
canal c'est à montigny le bretonneux une
librairie et qui poursuit son activité
grâce au click and collect et puis une
activité manuelle qui peut être utile et
qui sera en tout cas bonne pour la
planète
comment fabriquer sa propre lessive et
puis nous parlerons aussi de sport de
cinéma c'est parti pour ce premier
numéro de sion rentrée
et pour débuter cecelia qui m'a rejoint
bonjour célia genre qui dit confinement
dit forcément cuisine à la maison vous
allez nous donner des idées de recettes
faciles on l'espère en tout cas au moins
accessible pour moi qui ne suis pas un
grand cuisinier pour ce premier
rendez-vous direction le dos llano va
c'est à montigny le bretonneux
oui en compagnie de la chef de cuisine
lauriane baisa elle y concocte que des
plats italiens et elle a choisi pour
nous un des plats les plus appréciées
des français
alors aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter
la pâte carbonara qui est un plat
italien que tout le monde peut faire à
la maison
donc pour cela on va avoir besoin de
pecorino romano qui est un fromage de
brebis
on va également avoir besoin de lardons
composé de guan chalet qui est de la
joue de porc et également du spectre qui
est un jambon fumé
nous allons également avoir besoin de
neuf et nous on va uniquement utilisé le
jaune est également de linguini qui sont
des bateaux qui sont plus simples pour
la recette vous l'aurez compris quatre
ingrédients seulement frais et de bonne
qualité comme les pâtes par exemple ce
sont des linguine sèche au blé dur et
attention pas de crème dans les
carbonara salle les français le font
uniquement uniquement les français
réalisent la recette comme ça ce n'est
pas la vraie recette italienne original
et il ya plusieurs étapes la première
des étapes la première étape faire
revenir les lardons
on les fait revenir tout doucement
pour que le gras puisse fondre
j'allais le spectre vont apporter du
goût à la carbonara
il n'y a donc pas besoin de sel et
ensuite on baisse un peu le jeu et on va
des glaces et le jus de cuisson des
pâtes
il est exclu en même temps le gras ils
vont encore un petit peu plus
s on joue tranquillement
une fois que vous avez des glaces et il
faut attendre que le jus de cuisson soit
bien absorbées par les lardons deuxième
étape faire cuire les linguine dans un
grand volume d'eau salée et les mettre
ensuite dans la poêle
alors on va réduire le feu environ une
minute tu sors que les pâtes ne colle
pas et que ça laisse le temps aux pas
d'absorber le jus de cuisson
ensuite on va rajouter du poivre il faut
quand même en mettre suffisamment pour
donner du goût
et enfin troisième étape le jaune d'oeuf
maintenant nous allons ajouter un john
duff
donc c'est un jaune d'oeuf par personne
et de préférence à feux éteints alors
hors du feu donc là hop notre jaune
d'oeuf
ça me permet de lier la dernière étape
de la recette on va ajouter le pecorino
romano
une fois que le jus de cuisson est
totalement été on obtient une sauce bien
lié et il n'y a plus qu'a dressé et
voilà on a réalisé un cargo na en deux
trois minutes c'est un plat économique
que tout le monde peut faire chez soi il
est préférable de le manger directement
après la réalisation bon appétit
vous pouvez accompagner ce plat d'un
verre de vin rouge ou une eau plate
aussi fera très bien la faire un vin
italien de préférence des prêts
forcément merci ces liens on retrouve
bientôt pour d'autres recettes après un
bon repas un peu de sport à présent
n'oublions pas que pendant le premier
confinement plus d'un français sur deux
a pris du poids
première victime de ce manque d'activité
selon vous ces liens sont les hommes ou
les femmes les aime les hommes plus de
27 kg en moyenne 2,3 pour les femmes et
michael et demi d'euros est donc allé
prendre quelques conseils auprès de
caddies par hadji c'est miss fitness
france elle est aussi coach sportive à
voisins le bretonneux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plusieurs bénéfices à cet exercice
combiné vous allez travailler les
cuisses et les fessiers sur la flexion
total et il travaillait la ceinture
abdominale lors de l'extension total en
serrant le ventre au maximum surtout
vous allez garder l'alignement de la
colonne vertébrale
de plus vous allez aussi renforcer la
mobilité de vos articulations
bien que fermé en raison du confinement
la plupart de vos librairies de quartier
continue à proposer des services de
click and collect vous passez commande
en ligne vous prenez rendez vous pour
récupérer vos ouvrages c'est gratuit et
puis surtout à l inverse du premier
confinement les éditeurs continuent à
distribuer à proposer leurs nouveautés
ou différents revendeurs la librairie du
pavé du canal à montigny le bretonneux
propose ce service de click and collect
justin brasier est allé les chercher et
quelques conseils pour enrichir votre
fameuse palme votre pile à liv képi la
lire
en filmant oblige les activités en
extérieur sont donc réduits qu'il faut à
nouveau s'occuper à la maison et pour
cela aujourd'hui nous vous proposons de
la littérature avec les coups de coeur
de la librairie le pavé du canal à
montigny le bretonneux avec stéphanie
bonjour bonjour vous êtes responsable du
rayon littéraire et vous nous avez a
choisi nature humaine pourquoi
en fait il montre la beauté que peut
être notre planète mais avec toute la
complexité de pouvoir consommer sans
dégâts donc de photos en photo en fait
ils vont montrer que ce soit le monde
sous marin le monde terrestre ou tout
simplement l'environnement ce qu'est la
nature aujourd'hui et ce qu'elle risque
de devenir si on ne prend pas conscience
de quelque chose donc pas du tout mon
réalisateur c'est très beau les textes
sont profonds et les les photos sont
absolument extraordinaires avec value
est responsable du rayon jeunesse
bonjour bonjour vous vous avez un livre
de clémentine bové vous proposer tout à
fait qui s'appelle donc h tendre on est
dans un futur proche on n'est pas dans
une date précise
c'est juste que le stage de 3e dure plus
longtemps que ce que l'on a
habituellement et notre héros valentin
qui est un garçon introverti qui a
beaucoup de mal avec les changements se
retrouve en fait dans le nord de la
france dans les hauts de france alors
qu'il habite à albi dans le sud est qui
va se retrouver dans un ehpad est en
fait de son rapport de stage c'est ce
que nous allons lire en fête à
l'intérieur il va raconter ce qu'ils
voient ce qu'il connaît
[Musique]
avec pauline vous êtes la directrice de
la librairie le pavé du canal bonjour
bonjour est avec vous a parlé egypte
ancienne
oui tout à fait à travers un
documentaire qui s'adresse aux 8 9 ans
c'est à la fois un documentaire donc
avec des informations historiques très
simple qui résume bien les sujets
abordés voilà c'est par thème et vous
avez une petite boîte un coffre aux
trésors qui contient un masque funéraire
à fabriquer des pyramides l'enfant à
pouvoir aussi apprendre à écrire en
hiéroglyphes et un jeu traditionnel
égyptien
merci pour cette proposition je vous en
prie et on le rappelle même si les
digues ne sont pas considérés comme
essentiels ils sont toujours disponibles
en cliquant collecte le principe est
simple vous commander sur internet et
puis vous pouvez venir les chercher sur
place ou les faire livrer directement
chez vous et si vous ne jurez que par ce
fameux 5e arr sachez que tv 60,18 vous
propose cette semaine de nouvelle
édition de son rendez vous envie de
lecture patrice carmouze reçoit l des
auteurs des libraires eux aussi vous
feront part de leur choix invités
notamment l l'écrivain christophe maury
ou encore le philosophe pascal bruckner
de retour sur le plateau de simon
rentrait pour ce premier numéro pour
vous accompagner pendant le confinement
et 7 astrid qui m'a rejoint bonjour
astrid
vous allez nous donner quelques conseils
de do it yourself fabriquer soi même et
cette fois ci nous allons fabriquer de
la lessive exactement où le free la
lessive maison n'a que des avantages à
l'est écologique économique et c'est une
activité sympa à faire avec les enfants
pour la faire rien de plus simple il n'a
que quelques ingrédients 50 g de savon
noir 20 g de savon noir pardon 20 g de
savon de marseille indique le dos et une
cuillère à soupe de cristaux de soude
nous sommes allés voir cyril et valérie
klein ils sont tous les deux membres du
collectif vers higuain à la verrière et
ils font leurs recettes maison depuis
quatre ans on regarde la marche à suivre
on va mettre un litre d'eau à chauffer à
chauffer dans une casserole dans lequel
on va revenir venir mettre nos trois
ingrédients pour la cité tout à l'heure
savon de marseille
le savon noir et les cristaux de soude
on va laisser chauffer le mélange le
temps que les trois ingrédients se
dissolvent se dissolvent correctement et
après il suffit juste d'attendre que ça
refroidisse pour pouvoir le mettre dans
un contenant que vous aurez choisi
on va mettre un litre d'eau dans une
casserole
on va ajouter donc 20 g de savon de
marseille
soit vous pouvez mettre les savons dans
l'eau quand l'eau est froide soit vous
pouvez mettre les avants dans l'eau
l'eau est chaude et puis on termine en
ajoutant une cuillère à soupe de
cristaux de soude s'est fait à base de
créer de sel et donc ça un pouvoir
détergent également donc en fait là ce
qui est important à partir de maintenant
c'est que le savon de marseille fonde
voilà on n'est pas obligés de fouiller
tout à fait attendre que ça serait ce
que sonne pour une fois que le savon de
marseille aura fondu on va pouvoir
couper le feu ensuite on va attendre que
la lessive refroidissent on va attendre
qu'elles soient légèrement tiède et on
va pouvoir comme ça la mettre balle à la
passer en bouteille
voilà une des recettes de lessive c'est
tout simple et vraiment économe il ya
des variantes aussi d'autres façons de
faire oui plusieurs recettes existe il y
en a une autre à base de lierre et de
uniquement il suffit d'aller chercher
environ 50 feuilles de lierre et de
l'eau de les nettoyer de les hacher
pendant 15 minutes on met le lierre dans
un litre d'eau bouillante
après ces 15 minutes on éteint le feu et
on laisse infuser pendant environ 12
heures
ensuite il suffit juste de filtrer l'eau
le temps de s'occuper pendant le
confinement c'est ça c'est à faire le
soir plutôt la lessive elle peut se
garder plusieurs mois et pour l'utiliser
il suffit de mettre un verre de moutarde
dans le tambour directement très bien
merci astrid mes idées pour les
prochains jo it yourself peut-être le
produit pour laver le sol des choses
comme ça s'ils vont poser vos questions
et demandes et nous via nos réseaux
sociaux n'hésitez pas à nous interpeller
nous poser des questions nous ferons un
plaisir d'y répondre
merci astrid en attendant de retourner
au cinéma on l'espère bientôt pour
l'instant le 7e art et bien c'est à la
maison dans son canapé nous sommes allés
demander quelques conseils à un
versailles et c'est vincent mirabel il
est professeur de cinéma c'est aussi
l'auteur de l'histoire du cinéma pour
les nuls il nous propose un film à ne
pas manquer si vous êtes un amateur de
sean connery l'acteur écossais éternel
james bond n'a pas eu que ce rôle il
vient tout juste de nous quitter
peut-être voici ce film qui vous
permettra de le redécouvrir
fini le costume de l'agent 007 au
service de sa majesté
durant quinze ans sean connery va
revêtir le look d'un mentor au service
des plus jeunes
regardez le dans haute voltige il à la
barbe taillée
l'oeil vif le corps est plus lourd mais
l'esprit toujours aussi alerte il
incarne robert mc dougall un gentleman
cambrioleur spécialisé dans le vol
d'oeuvres d'art
il va guider et former une tenace
enquêtrice d'assurance qui s'est fait
passer pour une volume pour mieux le
coincer mais tout comme cette belle
jeune femme
le vieux baroudeur a plus d'un tour dans
son sac présenté en soirée de gala
d'ouverture au festival de cannes 1999
haute voltige a tout du film rassembleur
et attirant une histoire bien ficelée
riche en surprises deux acteurs vedettes
dont la très glamour
catherine zeta-jones trois braquages
spectaculaires trois sites des paysans
dont les fameuses twin towers de kuala
lumpur en malaisie
vraiment aucun risque de s'ennuyer
d'autant que le tandem vedette joie fou
le jeu du chat et de la souris et le
scénario offre jusqu'au bout un twist
plaisant pas étonnant que le producteur
réalisateur britannique fioles amiel et
rencontrer là son plus grand succès
rien de mieux une faute voltige pour
rêver oublier ses soucis et se distraire
en revoyant sean connery
allez nous refermons ce premier numéro
de si on rentre et on se retrouve jeudi
prochain à l'horaire habituel d'ici là
restez chez vous et portez vous bien
[Musique]